local real estate experts have said that
north las vegas will dominate new home
sales over the next decade one developer
hoping a new commercial project at lamb
and centennial parkway will attract even
more developers to what is a growing
area joe mohler there now with more on
the project and joe also got reaction
from the neighbors
oh brian we've done several stories
about the growth happening here in north
las vegas but residents say with this
growth they need more shopping centers
as well here at this empty lot at
centennial land like you would mention
will be a
new shopping experience for people who
live nearby
i lived here since 2012. driving around
north las vegas it's hard to miss all
the newly constructed homes hoping that
there is some restaurant
type development residents like fred
wilkins would like to see more food and
shopping options along with the growth
one developer plans to build that at
this location at centennial parkway and
lamb i would like to see some
changed restaurants maybe a pub
something a little closer this site will
be called the loop north las vegas is a
great place to build taylor lilly and
his family are bringing 70 thousand
square feet of commercial space to this
corner phase one is set to break ground
later this month he says the area needs
more businesses for locals it's going to
be a local's destination with
nightlife we have a tavern in there
which we operate scoundrels tavern and
eatery the project is said to create
dozens of jobs and convenience for those
living nearby
lilly says he wants to bring something
that is already in the other parts of
the valley to north las vegas it will
create a sense of community it'll it'll
be a place where people can come and
gather
and forget about
work and and covet and everything right
now you have to drive a few blocks to
get to a gas station
wilkins and others we spoke to say they
can't wait for dirt to move he says the
northeast is growing from aliante all
the way across it's coming to the land
the 215.
now back out here live you're taking
another look at this empty lot here for
now and they're planning to break ground
on this lot here uh later this month and
they say it will take eight to twelve
months to complete and it's just the
first phase of several reporting live in
north las vegas joe mohler eight news
now